jimmied so this is joint work with Ron
and John and vasilis and the paper is
accepted at Part C so it will be
presented in July in Spain and I'm happy
that we have the opportunity to also
spit presented to a more crypto centric
audience here so I want to start me talk
with the question which is assumed that
we want to do coin toss and we have two
products which we could use so the first
one is probably well known idea we both
commit to a bit we open our commitments
with some standard network assumption
and the result is the eggs are we could
also use this following protocol B which
starts in the way same way we both
commit to a bit and then we toss a coin
use this coin decide who goes first in
opening his commitment and then the
other party commit opens the commitment
and the result is the XOR so who's in
favor of using protocol a
who's in favor of using protocol be not
too many actually okay so let me baby
maybe explain where the big difference
is so here if we have standard Network
assumptions then the adversary might be
rushing he might wait for the other
party to open and then decide on whether
he opens his commitment after he has
already seen the outcome of this of this
opening the commitment and here this
coin toss here can be completely unfair
and it determines who's going to go
first so this coin toss might determine
that the adversary has to go first the
corrupted party has to go first in
opening the commitment which kind of
makes us it less likely for him to be
able to influence the outcome of the
cantos we do it for example by this
protocol pain can be completely unfair I
might have said that that this step can
be completely unfair again and the rest
of the talk I want to kind of formalize
this intuition that this type of
protocol might be somehow better than
this type of protocol well I mean he has
a probability here he has a probability
if he say he wants to to make the output
be a zero and he's absolutely fixed to
this then here he can do with
probability one-half and with the other
half probability he can aboard here well
if he has to go first in opening he
would have to abort right away whereas
otherwise he could see what the other
party opens and he might be able to
force it to zero as well but overall
only with a probability of 1 over 4 so
in this sense I mean this is not a good
not a secure coin toss it's just somehow
quantitatively better than the other one
okay so the rest of the talk will be
about fairness insecure function
evaluation which means we have two
parties so most of the top would be
about the two-party case we have two
parties which provide an input they
compute this function f the result is
that and I will not talk about the
correctness of the result or the privacy
of the inputs I only care about the
fairness so we know at least since 1986
that fairness in the setting is
impossible to achieve fairness sorry I
should have said that before means that
if one party learns it out put the other
one should also learn it it doesn't mean
that they learn the output it just means
it shouldn't be one party and the other
learning it not not learning it okay so
intuitively the possible outcomes of
this of such a protocol run might be
that no one gets the output that only
this guy gets the output only this guy
gets the output or both guys get the
output and the standard definition of
fairness would mean these two got these
two outcomes here if we consider this
guy is being corrupted these two
outcomes of the protocol would be good
because the honest guy gets the output
this year would be good because at least
the dishonest guy also doesn't get the
output this would be bad and the
standard way of defining fairness would
be that this outcome should be well at
least very unlikely like negligible
probability all right so we know this is
impossible to achieve and what we try or
would we do in this work is we try to be
as good as possible but for defining
what it means to be as good as possible
we somehow have to attach the i use to
these what do we find good what if I'm
bad how good we think these outcomes are
and we capture this by by providing
utility by defining utility basically
the adversary's utility on that he gets
when we achieve each of these outcomes
so this is kind of related to game
theory and there is a connection to game
theory which I will explain
in a cup of slaves so this means in the
end that if we are in this line here the
adversary will you gain utility gamma 0
0 if they're if we're in this line it's
gamma 1 0 so always the first digit
means whether the adversary gets the
output the second digit means whether
the honest party gets the output now
there are some natural assumptions which
make throughout this work which is the
least preferred option for the adversary
is that he does not get the output but
the honest part it is and the the option
he likes most is the one where only he
gets the output it's kind of restricted
but some are natural and then what we're
going to do is based on these values
we're going to compute for each protocol
an adversary what the result what the
payoff of the adversary is and we will
define a protocol as being good if it
restricts the adversary as much as
possible as for if for any adversary
strategy we could use the payoff is as
low as possible okay we're of course not
the first ones to try and define R
estrella relaxed versions of fairness
i'd like to mention that there are
several approaches of the gradual
release type which basically the
original work by a corpus 11 was of the
type you learn a somewhat noisy version
of the output and then over the rounds
of the protocol we reduce there are the
noise and you learn kind of more
information about the output gradually V
this work here is called resource
fairness it's somehow a similar idea it
means it's very hard to compute the
output in the beginning and then we
reduce in each round the complexity a
party has to invest in order to to
compute the output so these are relaxed
notions of fairness which can somehow
give information to the party's over
time
then there has been a treatment in a
purely game theoretic setting which is
quite different from what we do on a
formal level and there was the one that
is actually most related on a formal in
a formal sense as one of a pea security
by Gordon and cuts which basically means
the security only has to hold with with
probability 1 minus 1 over P so they can
be a polynomial gap between for the
security ok now formally what we do is
based on something that we published two
years ago which we call duration of
protocol design and here is where kind
of the game theory part of the paper is
so but it's not a game in which we play
the protocol it's kind of a metagame in
which we have two players one we call
the protocol designer and one is the
attacker and the protocol designer
determines a protocol the attacker
defines a strategy to attack the
protocol so the protocol here is
actually a message in that game it's not
the strategy that is used in that game
and the solution concept who use here is
an absolute sub game perfect equilibrium
so if a protocol is such a solution then
it kind of restricts the attacker as
much as possible we define the game to
be zero sum game so the utility of the
designer is the negative of the utility
of the attacker so what I still have to
tell you is how we define these
utilities and that works as follows this
is a kind of idealized functionality
that we would like to achieve for fair
sfe its affair as a fee functionality
for coin toss it would be perfect coin
toss functionality but we know that we
cannot achieve that functionality so the
first step we do is we kind of Hammer
that functionality and it gets some kind
of a crack here
so now that we can prove that there
exists a simulator such that the
protocol with repetitive respect to that
simulator realized that functionality
then we define events in the idea of
functionality basically we define events
that this crack is exploited in the
ideal execution and we assign the
payoffs to the fact that the ideal
adversary actually exploits the cracks
and the functionality and finally we say
the payoff of an adversary is the payoff
of the simulator that achieves the least
pay off why the least so this is the
real adversary this is the ideal
adversary which is kind of the proof
technique that we use in the simulation
based proofs and so this one plays
against us this kind of a moral high
level argument this one is our proof
technique as good as we get the proof
will be so on a more technical basis if
we find a simulator such that this event
has to be used very rarely or maybe not
at all it means that the real adversary
didn't achieve any attack or only with
small probability that would kind of
correspond to use of that crack and the
functionality so it means as good I mean
if we prove a simulator that achieves a
small payoff that uses this crack very
early then actually with the adversary
did succeed in breaking the protocol
okay so now if I use this to define
fairness this is my functionality for
fair to party secure function evaluation
the parties give their inputs we compute
the output and possibly we output either
nothing or we output Z to both parties
parties and we know that we cannot
realize that functionality so now I
introduce that crack shift of the image
okay which basically will allow a
corrupted party to break this guarantee
that only these two possibilities exist
and will allow him to determine well
first where this guy should get the
output and second whether he will get
the output and then in the proof of a
protocol what I need to do is first
prove that the protocol really realizes
that functionality and second what I
know now will have to prove is the
statement of the payoff that any
adversary can get for this i define
events and this ideal execution as you
described before so these are these four
events neither party gets the output
only be honest only the corrupted or
both get the output and I assign these
payoff values I explained earlier
I find the payoff of a simulator as kind
of the expected payoff so for each of
the possible outcomes I give this payoff
so overall the expected payoff and I
define as explained before the pay of
the real adversary as being the payoff
of the simulator of the valid simulator
that achieves the least value here okay
what we show in the paper is that the
following protocol actually achieves
this value and this value means this is
the payoff for the adversary to get the
output and the honest party not getting
it it's the 10 case so here the
adversary is really successful and this
here is the payoff for both parties
actually getting the output ok so the
roughly speaking the best what the
protocol achieves is that in half the
cases the adversary has a full win and
the other half the cases it's going to
be a draw where both get the outlets so
the protocol is very similar to the
protocol b-type coin toss I explained
earlier what we do is we use an unfair
sfe as a sub protocol and in this unfair
sfe we compute the following we compute
a random index which is either one or
two and we compute a sharing of the
actual output value just a caveat this
will have to be authenticated in a way
of left that out for simplicity so it's
a sharing of the output value and I each
party gets a share so each party gets
the I star and a share in case this
particular board we just start started
from up here and then we exchange the
shares just as we did in the coin toss
protocol and then what we also show is
that this is actually optimal so no
protocol can achieve a payoff smaller
than that
so the proof idea here is if the
protocol of boards in any step up here
we didn't release any information so
it's fine to start to start again and
then the second part of the proof which
is proving that this payoff is again not
larger than that and we use that the
simulator actually has to produce this
output to a corrupted party and in this
output you can choose the istore
uniformly at random or actually he has
to choose it uniformly at random and so
only in one of those cases where
actually the i star corresponds to the
index of the corrupted party the
simulator will have to use the breaking
of the functionality in the other case
it's the honest party can always restart
the protocol and compute its own output
so the honest party if the adversary if
the adversary is chosen to send its
value first the honest party can always
obtain the output and in that case the
best thing the adversary can achieve is
that both get the output so we get this
payoff that you okay what I have to show
you as well yep
for other person
we assume that for each function there
exists a default input for the party yes
I mean basically the function needs to
be the function and the specification of
a department but in that case it would
be the 01 because only the honest party
gets the output and the adversary does
not and by assumption this is the
smallest value so it would be not good
for the adversary to actually provoke
that situation because it's more than
that well if he doesn't abort you want
to compute the computation of you like
often off your honest inputs right just
if you know that he is corrupted then
all right I mean it might be easier to
write in that case just evaluate the
function it's really probably I should
have written it that way yeah it's kind
of boring to run the protocol with only
one party right thank you I mean we make
the assumption that we know that we have
information about the incentive of the
adversary and this is what I said before
we have we assume that for the adversary
it's most favorable to actually break
fairness and it's less favorable to have
the honest party learned
Chiefs gamma 1 0 plus gamma bomb on over
to what does it tell me it depends on
what measure you put to those incentives
but basically what you can read it as in
if you want to think about it in terms
of probabilities it means that with
probability one-half the output is going
to be one unfair and with probability
one-half you're going to have a fair
outcome of the protocol so what's
important is actually not the actual
values of the payoff I'd rather the fact
that this payoff can give you an
absolute value that you can prove them
at its optimal right we don't really
care you know whether that's five or six
or seven you don't really care about if
you care about the ordering and in order
to blow up the manatee you will show
that there is an adversary I can get
this payoff I think that's where yeah so
the next step is proving the optimality
and what I want to do here is I want to
roughly explain how we can get an
adversary strategy that thieves that
payoff and the strategy is actually very
simple so we have one if the adversary
corrupts this one and one corrupting
this one so it's a purely aesthetic
strategy it means corrupt someone and
run the answer protocol and in each
round you assume that the other guy
won't continue here boards and you just
compute what your protocol does and then
either your protocol will give the
correct output or it will give you no
output at all that we get from the
correctness of the protocol
I mean the gradual released I protocols
they might give you wrong output which
means they don't achieve correctness so
they would just not be covered by the
definition so if we get so if the
adversary actually gets the value then
he's going to board and otherwise he's
going to continue the protocol and we do
this for every round so it's a very
simple strategy that's all we have to do
now in each round what can happen both
parties actually now run the on strategy
in the round so they do nothing fancy
even if one is corrupted with this
strategy so we can define the following
events basically that in each runs we
can see whether a party would output the
value in case the other one would abort
and it for each of the rounds either it
is only this guy out putting the value
or it is only this guy out putting the
value or both would be starting to out
within the same round okay those are all
cases that can can occur now the proof
idea continues as follows a protocol
should never give both parties the value
in the same round because otherwise both
parties could output after getting their
message and before sending their message
to the other party okay so it is not
good for a protocol to output the value
in in the same round to both parties and
we can actually prove that we can
improve any protocol kind of removing
such wraps by removing cetera and then
in the very end at least one party is
first with probability at least one half
so if the adversary chooses the particle
to corrupt uniformly at random what he's
going to get is well with probability
one-half he's going to to create an
unfair outcome and with the remaining
probability of fair outcome so that's
the lower bound yeah
a stupid question let's assume there's a
good all there Ellis always slows the
output first and now if the adversary is
Ellis then it has this gamma 10 tail if
the adversary's Bob he will always about
I guess in this case so it has some
gamma 0 0 they open are we going to
assume the adversary is Ellis with
probability one-half and Bob bit
provable to hang out like now in the end
we Mak we use the adversary that
achieves to the maximum pay off so in
that case the adversary would be Allison
T would always win so that's just the
definition ok since I have some minutes
left I was likely safe something about
the multi-party case and now what we
consider it the multi-party case is the
standard crypto central adversary model
so we are not going to make a statement
where we have rational parties competing
against each other but now it's really
we have one central adversary who tries
to break the protocol and the
functionality looks very similar to the
two-party case and breaking the
functionality also means achieving a
state where not all honest parties get
the output but the adversary gets the
output so the events are defined similar
as before if no party gets the output we
are in the 00 case if exactly the honest
parties but not the adversary get the
output it's this 0-1 case and so on and
so forth and now in this case we
consider the case where we have this
total order on on the payoff so I
changed this year in the middle to be a
strict inequality instead of not stating
any relation for them for simplicity and
what we can now show is that different
protocols can achieve different kind of
curves depending on the number of
corrupted parties so one example is
standard sfe protocols
they can achieve full fairness if less
than n half parties are corrupted and
full unfairness otherwise but also we
can give protocols which somehow give a
proportional to the number of corrupted
parties type of fairness so if say three
or four of the parties are corrupted so
we here then the adversary gets quite a
bit of payoff but he doesn't get like
full unfairness but what we pay is that
we get some unfairness here in the case
of one quarter okay so what we can show
is first of all in terms of the area
below the curve this protocol is optimal
so there exists no protocol which for
which we can kind of put the curve even
lower and what one can also show it's
not in the paper is that there are
certain restrictions in how this curve
can go so for example it has to be
monotone and things like that
interestingly the standard as a few
protocols we can easily show them to be
optimal for the case where the number of
party is parties is odd but we don't
know what happens for the case where the
number of parties is even I mean whether
we can have an Optima procrit that which
follows the standard as a V type of
curve here ok so the protocol that
achieves this line is actually more or
less the multi-party version of the
two-party protocol the rough idea is you
give the output to some party at random
and hope that it distributed among all
parties
okay so going back to this here these
two to the related work these works are
not really related so it's a different
paradigm in the sense so the rationale
fairness paper here by a shelf Kennedy
has I really assumes rational parties
whereas for us the rational part is only
in building the security definition so
their solution is also not really
closely related to ours so 1 over P
security is something which is a which
is a closed are related to our work but
what I'd like to highlight is our
protocol work for arbitrary functions
and our negative result is about there
exists a function which has exponential
output input and output sets for which
the negative result holds whereas their
protocols are for restricted function
classes so they achieve more for
restricted function classes which means
at least one of the domains or ranges of
input or output have to be polynomial
size so in that case they can achieve
much more fairness so our result which
would come would correspond to achieving
one over to here where's for them p can
be an arbitrary polynomial and formally
it's a bit more relaxed in the sense
that they don't fully they cannot fully
guarantee correctness because the output
and the protocol might be randomized
okay what I want to say is we did this
in this duration of protocol design
framework we published some two years
ago and what's nice about this is it
supports a composition so we can have we
instantiate this usually in nuc so we
can use hybrid functionalities and
approves or that framework that we
developed in crypto which is pretty
difficult for a game theory definitions
and of the treatment we have it
generalizes to reactive functionalities
it's actually a follow-up paper but as
Ranjit also mentioned in his talk
it's become more complicated there and
the reason at least in our case is that
we cannot just restart the protocol or
do some computation only honor the local
input because the adversary might have
learned something already in the
previous step of the protocol okay but
also somehow the protocol get a bit more
interesting in that case and one thing
that I'd like to say is Rosario has
mentioned that we're looking for
different definition of kind of rational
commitment and in our work which should
be similar from the type of setting
there to his work it's actually quite
easy to do this so we can give a
reactive functionality for commitment
like get the input and only output
constant to the receiver on open we
output the committed value and now we
simply define how this functionality can
be broken if each of the parties is
corrupted which means either here we
allow to break the functionality and
replace the output or in that case we
allowed to break the functionality and
allow this party to get the input
earlier so we don't have protocol or so
for this but I think this is at least a
good starting point for a definition
operational commitment in the setting
that he was considering it's not for the
setting where both parties are regional
and try to compute it for whatever
reason okay yeah so I've shown you that
we can use this general framework to
analyze kind of quantitative and
optimality type notion of sav fairness
and I've also shown you the protocol's
and yeah the reactive case is more is
more complicated and we hope to publish
it soon
that's it thank you
like high-level question with a field
where do you think the field oh forget
something is making theory or in
especially in particular in relation to
grip the boy is a much more to be done
from exciting challenge like gilded from
NW or something I mean maybe maybe I
misunderstood your question but this is
this is early it has a relation to game
theory but it's not that it results or
game theory of equal gaming TV / 50
susumu interesting for me right now so
exactly alike where you use game theory
to I don't know get a possibility for
our current disability fix it so you get
your ass in for an open question during
all this I mean one thing which is for
sure open is applying this to other
areas like the rational commitment or
how is this relation as I as a said I
mean can we really then use this in the
work that Rosaria did for example so
there are some open questions in this
area there's some detail open question
which we kind of leave open in terms of
if the order of the payoff is different
we don't capture all orders but it's not
a huge open question in that sense yeah
your framework that passing to the
independent of the inputs right for
flying car games you know make the path
made have had that what card you're
holding oh cards on holding or something
like that let's input dependent payoff
framework that make sense
that's an open maybe that's your game is
open question maybe that's because we
take that essentially we define the
payoff we have the worst possible
environment and it definitely makes
sense to define it over a restricted
class of environments and then you know
for certain includes we give different
pay off but then you will lose some
position we definitely mixes other
question